this aid needs to go to innocent
civilians and not Hamas we're going to
be watching very carefully how it's
delivered we're given the money we know
the money is fungible and then we hand
over the money and then Biden State
Department spokesman Matt Miller admits
that we don't know what the hell they're
going to do with the money I I think the
the the concern the Israeli government
has and they' said this publicly and
they certainly said it privately to us
is that any assistance that goes in will
be diverted once it's inside Gaza that
there is not a there's not an Israeli
military force in Gaza there's not a Un
Peace Keeping force in Gaza the people
with guns inside Gaza are Hamas and so
Hamas may try to divert this assistance
and keep it from getting to the
civilians who who it is intended for we
think that's a legitimate concern uh
We've made clear that this aid needs to
go to innocent civilians and not Hamas
we're going to be watching very
carefully how it's delivered um because
we want to be sensitive to those
concerns which we
share I I this this the whole show can
we title this show Dave doesn't know how
to comment on the stupidity like he's
admitting it the I are like oh Hamas is
running the show you're giving them 100
million they have all the guns we have
no ability to manage what's going on
down there and what do you mean so what
do you mean we're going to make sure the
money gets the people who need it like
what does that mean like the average
guys and okay here's 20 bucks good luck
like what are we even talking about we
are literally paying Hamas and they're
they're full on admitting
it